well gentlemen is now down to the two
you guys to battle it out for the title
of fortune fire champion and so
congratulations
in this final round we're gonna be
sending you guys back home to build an
iconic weapon from history and that
weapon is
homemade machete
this lethal machete was once wielded by
the legendary all-female army in western
africa known as the dahume amazons
the long slightly curved blade flared
out to a wide tip giving the female
warriors the ability to deliver fatal
blows that cut clean through bone and
flesh in a single blow
these skilled women warriors were an
elite fighting force and extremely
intimidating often carrying trophies of
their fallen enemies the machetes were a
powerful weapon designed to cleave
through anything that got in their way
today the dahomey machete can be seen
wielded in the 2020 hbo series lovecraft
country
you guys will have four days to work on
your blades i want you to both bring us
back a blade worth at least ten thousand
dollars we'll see you guys in four days
all right glock man my name is alex
morris i'm 48 years old from walworth
rhode island what i like most about
bladesmithing is it's challenging and i
believe that if we don't challenge
ourselves we don't grow
i'm super excited to get after this
thing and then goes to steal the biggest
challenge will be drawing out the end of
the blade
this is new for me i'm
probably going to take me a while to
figure out how i'm going to move the
steel to get it to where i want it to go
i'm liking it it's getting there i want
to make damascus billet for the two disc
shaped guards and hopefully heat treat
my blade i stick some weld on there and
i'm going to get them to forge after i
clench
this is crucial this is big right here
yeah
good
i think we're good i think my blade's
coming out pretty well right now i'm
cleaning up my damascus if none of the
knives break out there they're gonna
start looking at those things the
damascus will help my blade stand out
against atoms
ah broken half
the last forge welds i did last night
was not taken so
now i'm like starting over completely on
my guards and pommel so i wasted a lot
of time doing that damascus and turned
out for nothing this is a hard challenge
man this is taxing
my name is adam kumar and i'm a
firefighter paramedic in city tour new
york my wife and my kids are very
supportive and like that i do life
making my two children they're both
makers as well and i couldn't be any
prouder of both of them i have never
made anything this big before if i win
i'm going to disneyland i think right
now my biggest obstacle is the size of
the piece this piece of metal is so
thick and so large it's taking forever
to heat up
just not moving i'm growing impatient i
think there's enough steel here i
actually cut off a piece it's starting
to move but
very nervous about how thin this blade
actually is starting to become i don't
want it to break or shatter
i put some pressure on it with the angle
grinder ended up doing too much pressure
and it broke my heart sinks now
i have to restart
there's no way i can send this in to be
tested
day four final day make it or break it
so yesterday i definitely made the
comeback it's time to assemble
i start working on my actual physical
handle i just don't want to use a piece
of wood i want to dress it up a little
bit so i twist three different strands
of wire so it's going to have an
alternating pattern the handle is
looking great it's better than i
imagined
my kids came downstairs to check on me
how's the machete coming oh that's
really cool do you like that yeah i
could tell they're proud of me sticking
it through and being able to produce a
tangible item it's a proud dad moment it
will kill it will cure
bait fits welcome to the kill test
i will take your machete and deliver
some lethal blows on this ballistics
dummy
alex you're first you ready for this yes
sir
i'm most concerned about everything with
this test i'm not sure it's sharp enough
i'm not sure it's strong enough i don't
know what it's going to do to my plate i
have no idea
[Music]
[Music]
all right alex the bounce you have your
blade is nice for every cut i can really
control and feel like i'm chopping in
there the edge no issues at all it is
still very sharp
more importantly sir your machete you
will kill
thanks
all right adam it's time to have fun
with your blade are you ready sir yes
sir
i hope my blade doesn't break i had a
lot of setbacks making this blade you
know i had to start over i hope it
doesn't come back to bite me in the butt
saying a little prayer please don't
break please don't breathe please don't
break
[Music]
yes
all right now let's talk about your
weapon here this is a very forward heavy
blade
but that forward weight really cuts deep
into this ballistics dummy overall sir
it will keel
that's worth it right there i go home
now
all right gentlemen you know what time
it is it's time for the strength test
the shield chop
what i want to see on top of how durable
your blades are is their effectiveness
against that shield all right so alex
you're up first you ready yes sir
[Music]
[Music]
all right so alex
obviously there's a
bit of an issue what happened here is
you can you can see the grain size it
looks
like 40 grit sandpaper which is really
really large grain
and then right here
is that black yeah that was a crack okay
so that crack existed probably during
the heat treat once i hit
just face onto the shield it just cut
loose
alex we hate to see that your blade had
a catastrophic failure but you are not
out of the fight just yet your blade
broke on the fourth strike so that means
adam in order to become fortune fire
champion your homie machete must survive
four strikes you ready yes
everything is riding on these four
strikes i need my machete to hold
together i've got to make it through
this
well adam you survived your four strikes
that means you are the forge of fire
champion so congratulations
alex
unfortunately you didn't win this round
you crush it in round one in round two
but your time the forge has ended i'm
gonna have to ask you to please step off
the fourth floor
thanks i'm a little disappointed but i'm
definitely proud of the machete that i
made
making something this big was quite a
challenge it's a learning process so i'm
definitely glad i had this opportunity
i'm glad i get to know all these other
smiths this was fun it was it was a
blast
well adam your blade survived the four
strikes it's a beautiful beast and it
just won you ten thousand dollars in the
title of forge and fire champions
congratulations man
well done is it everything you thought
it would be
and more
it's been an honor it's been a pleasure
wow learning experience it's kind of
surreal but it's a great feeling it's
awesome
my family supported me so kids we're
going to disney
you